day five of the trial of the state of
New Mexico versus Wayne bent the
presentation of evidence is complete but
before the jury makes its decision the
state and defense present their closing
arguments this case is not about
religion it is not about making a
determination if mr. Bence beliefs are
correct or wrong if they're better than
anyone elses beliefs this case is about
mr. Bence misusing his trust and
authority over these two young girls he
used his position of authority to cost
these girls come to his room to lay
naked and while they laid naked he
committed criminal sexual contact this
is my new BFF let me tell you why
because the state has to prove criminal
sexual contact he would have had to
touch intimate parts of the body and
both girls got on the stand and I said
did he touch you anywhere on your body
if you were wearing a bikini that would
have been covered by the bikini and the
girls said no the jury retires to
deliberate its verdict a gag order has
prevented Wayne bent from talking to the
media but now with the testimony and
complete he's free to speak his mind
they killed Jesus for a lie
and it's up to this generation to prove
what its gonna do with this but they had
to lie about Jesus to get rid of him and
they would have to do the same to me
he's a liar everything he says is a lie
I mean let's make it real you know and
he's slept with his daughter-in-law he's
got seven he's got seven women he slept
with I mean that's the reality I mean
that's what's real it's he says all
spiritual then why is he physically
sleeping with them why do they
physically have to lay in bed with him
if it's spiritual it's a lie everything
he says everything he says
unaware of any tension Lakeisha takes
the chance to embrace the man accused of
molesting her wayne bent declares that
he'll stop eating if he's found guilty
back in October 2008 Benton many of his
followers fasted in protest over the
charges brought against him when he
failed to make a court appearance he was
arrested and put in jail for 22 days if
I go to jail again I am NOT going to
live there I will know how long that
process will use just denying any food
water well I think I would probably
drink water but it would be a prayer
time asking God to deliver me and if he
didn't deliver me I would die there but
I'm not going to live in prison with all
of you fast
everyone here yeah you couldn't ask me
that question because I don't know I
know what I would do but I wouldn't I
don't invite anybody to do what I do but
I'm not their controller and I'm not
their dictator and I've never tried to
get them to do anything